let me ask you about firefighting
what do you think it means to be a great
firefighter
and a great man a great human being
in a situation like you were in in 9 911
you know that's that's kind of a broad
term like some you know you can go to
different firehouses and they might have
a different definition of what they
consider a great firefighter
but i think in the industry as a whole
if you're willing to put
everyone else before you
especially your team
you know as we say there ain't no i in
team right it's t-e-a-m and there's no i
in there it's all about those guys and
girls next to you
if you can do that
that makes you pretty great
you you put everything else
second and you just run in and you run
in with that team for strangers
you know i i've had the the honor of i
spent almost 25 years of my adult life
serving
humanity my country
my former city
and the people i worked with were giants
and i don't mean that in height i mean
but i mean that in spirit and in soul
i saw some of the most heroic selfless
acts
and then i saw some of the behind the
scenes that were so impressive you know
we'd go to a fire around christmas
and the family would lose everything
and even when i was a cop same thing
you'd come back either to the police
precinct or the firehouse or the ems
station
and someone would put together a
collection and say hey guys hey lex 50
bucks a man
you know the smiths down the street just
lost everything we're gonna go get some
presents for the kids and some turkeys
and not one of those guys questioned
that
and they were making 12 25 an hour and
they still came up with 50 bucks for
that family but see that's the stuff the
press won't show you right they don't
want to show that humanity that soft
edge
see when you're a warrior you need to
have this rough shield this rough
exterior
because if you don't you die
but
a true great
firefighter or responder or a cop or
military personnel
they have that rough exterior with that
soft on their belly that that that you
know like that's it that heart right
it's there and and that's to me the true
great ones
some of them they just have a hard time
doing that you know there's no shame in
showing your soft side you know well you
got your dad to say i love you back no
all right that was huge that was that
took that took me 22 years
so you were a firefighter for 21 almost
22 years yeah what what why did you
become a firefighter oh my dad i mean i
i i was five years old when i went to
his firehouse and there was these you
know at the time they looked like giants
to me with mustaches and they you know
and the trucks the truck smelled like
smoke and the gear smelled like smoke
and the tires and you know the diesel
fuel and i was like
this is this is what i'm gonna do and
then and then they bring you in the
kitchen and they stuff you with ice
cream and cake and everything you know
and then i go home with my mom you know
shaking with a
sugar comber and she's mad at my dad but
yeah it was just oh i was like i gotta
do this it was like
they were like a baseball team in a
garage with a truck and these big tools
and big coats and helmets and they were
just laughing and having fun and i'm
like yeah man i'm doing this and i knew
i was obsessed with it i mean i was so
pissed the fireman's test came out when
i was 14 and i couldn't take it you had
to be 18.
and and it was done you know you know
test was graded and whatever so my dad
you know now there's a copy circulating
because it's it's old now and he goes
hey this is what you're in for
and i took it i and i you know did it
like it was real and i got a 99 and i
was so pissed i said i want to get hired
he goes you can't you're 14. like but i
wanted i just wanted to do it so bad
and and i just wanted to help people i
just wanted to be like my dad you know
like he'd come home smiling as tired as
he was and he fought fires in the 60s
and 70s when the city was burning
and he's still as exhausted as he was
he'd still be smiling
i wanted to smile at work and i used to
i got paid to laugh and joke
i got paid to cry sometimes
but man we laughed a lot we really it
was the the chop breaking is just it's
just unending and it's great
you